and so if you're only chasing the mighty
dollar you're enjoying it so the
question is where does passion come from
people put harley-davidson logos on
their body you are in love because you
work very hard how do you feel like
really excited actually let me tell you
a story so a friend of mine and I we
went for a run in Central Park on the
weekends they host races and it's very
common at the end of the race they'll
give away something and on this
particular day there were some free
bagels and on one side was a group of
volunteers and on the other side was a
long line of runners waiting to get
their free bagel so I said to my friend
let's get a bagel and he looked at me
and said that lines too long and I said
free bagel and he said I don't want to
wait in line and I was like free bagel
and he says not let's it's too long and
that's when I realized that there's two
ways to see the world some people see
the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want I could only see the
bagels he could only see the line and so
I walked up to the line I leaned in
between two people and pulled out two
bagels and no one get mad at me because
the rule is you can go after whatever
you want
you just cannot deny anyone else
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it you can break the rules you just
can't get in the way of somebody else
getting what they want that you can
breathe that's rule number one
how do we do that in a way that can
serve other like when we see a rule that
is really frustrating most people will
just complain we're entrepreneurs we
will still get upset but we'll use that
anger and frustration and turn it into
something positive you can break the
rules that's rule number one
[Music]
he's an author speaker and consultant
who writes on leadership and management
he joined the RAND Corporation in 2010
where he advises on military innovation
in planning he's known for popularizing
the concepts of the golden circle and to
start with why he's simon Sinek
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number six is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all through to the end for some
special bonus clips and as always if
Simon says something that really really
resonates with you please leave it down
in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well what does it mean to
perform under pressure in the work that
you do
performing under pressure whether it's
me or anybody else is the same you know
I have the same pressures as anyone else
there's time and there's performance
there's financial there's deadlines my
pressures are not unique the situations
may be different you know but but
everybody has the same kinds of pressure
what I find fascinating is the
interpretation of the stimuli let me
explain
so I was watching the Olympics and I was
amazed at how bad the questions were
that the reporters would ask all the
athletes and almost always they asked
the same question
were you nervous and to a tee all the
athletes went no and what I realized is
it's not that they're not nervous it's
their interpretation of what's happening
in their body what happens when you're
nervous your heart rate starts to go
your you know you sort of get a little
tangi get a little sweaty
you have expectation of what's coming
and we interpreted that is I'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you get a
little sort of like tense you're
anticipating what's coming and it's all
the same thing except these Olympic
quality athlete have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say as nervous as excited that
they also the same thing no I'm not
nervous I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous identify that this
is excitement I used to speak in front
of a large audience and somebody say how
do you feel it's a little nervous now
when somebody says how do you feel like
really excited actually and it it came
from just sort of telling myself no no
this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on but it's
kind of a remarkable thing to deal with
pressure by interpreting what your body
is experiencing as excitement rather
than nerves and it's really kind of
effective but it makes you want them to
rush for is rather than pull back and
yet it's the same experience in making
the conscious choice to deviate that
that's the game that makes all the
different train your mind
[Music]
I talked to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hard-working kid
and there right out of college their
their entry-level jobs and I'll ask them
how is it going and they'll say I think
I'm gonna quit
[Music]
they say to me not making an impact
I'm like you know you've been here eight
months right they treat the sense of
fulfillment
[Music]
or even love
like it's a scavenger hunt
[Music]
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was mutual
or they're quitting because they're not
making an impact
a job you find joy from is not something
you discover it's not like I found love
here it is
I found a job I love that's not how it
works both of those things require hard
work you are in love because you work
very hard every single day of your life
to stay in love serve those around you
and you maintain that joy it's not a
discovery
[Music]
but the problem is the sense of
impatience I love finding shortcuts I
love finding hags it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the male
[Music]
this large emove object but doesn't mean
you have to do your time that's not what
I'm talking about
it's working smart and working hard take
a helicopter climb I don't care
there's still a mountain
but the Simon's point there is still
about life career fulfillment
relationships our journeys
you have made 5000 videos for this
channel
now can you get there faster than me
sure but it's still a long road we still
have to be patient you still have to put
in the work the problem is this entire
generation
it has an institutionalized sense of
impatience as they want the immediate
results they want the immediate success
and we don't get it then they quit and
do they have the patience to go on the
journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled and so understand that this is
a deep passion of yours is something
that go on to commit potential rest we
like to know that you care about it so
much
[Music]
what did they just quit and on to the
next dump
ghost and under the next
[Music]
then expect this sucker to start
expected to take a long time
but expect to be committed and stay
patient
[Music]
in the 18th century there was something
that spread across Europe and eventually
made its way to America
wearable fever also known as the Black
Death of child bed basically what was
happening is women were giving birth and
they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
[Music]
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of Europe and it got worse and
worse and worse over the course of over
a century
[Music]
in some hospitals it was as high as 70%
of women who gave birth who would die as
a result of giving birth but this was
the Renaissance this was the time of
empirical data and we had thrown away
things like tradition and mysticism
these were men of science these were
doctors and these doctors and men of
science wanted to study and try and find
the reason for this black death of child
bed and so they got to work studying
[Music]
and they would study the corpses of the
of the women who had died and in the
morning they would conduct autopsies and
then in the afternoon they would go into
liver babies
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s that dr. Oliver Wendell Holmes
father of Supreme Court justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes realized that all of
these doctors who conducting autopsies
in the morning weren't washing their
hands before they delivered babies in
the afternoon and he pointed it out and
said guys you're the problem and they
ignored him and called him crazy
for 30 years until finally somebody
realized that if they simply washed
their hands it would go away and that's
exactly what happened when they started
sterilizing their instruments and
washing their hands the black death of
childbed disappeared my point is the
lesson here is sometimes you're the
problem we've seen this happen all too
recently with our new men of science
men of Finance and my point is is take
account ability for your action you can
take all the credit in the world for the
thing that you do right as long as you
also take responsibility for the things
you do wrong it must be a balanced
equation
[Music]
you get to take credit when you also
take accountability you don't get it one
way and not the other
[Music]
you
I spoke at an education summit from
Microsoft I also spoke at an education
summit for Apple at the education summit
for Microsoft I would say that 70% of
the executives spent about 70% of their
presentations talking about how to beat
Apple at the Apple education summit a
hundred percent of the executives spent
a hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn one is
playing this way and one is playing that
[Music]
one is playing finite and the other one
is playing innocent gets which one gets
frustrated so at the end of my talk at
Microsoft that gave me a gift they gave
me the new Zune when it was a thing and
let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology I've ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular I've absolutely loved it it
was easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and it didn't work on iTunes
which is a different problem I couldn't
use it but but it was amazing and
elegant my god it was elegant so I'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior Apple executive sort of
employee number twelve kind of guy and
you know I like to stir pots so I turned
him I said you know Microsoft gave me
their new zoom and it is so much better
than your iPod Touch and he turned to me
and he said I have no doubt because the
infinite player understands sometimes
your head and sometimes your behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it works the football isn't to
be the best every day
the goal isn't to outdo your competition
every time then that's a finite
construction Devine and sent to
Microsoft I've got the new iPod Touch
it's so much better than your Zune they
would have said can we see it what does
it do react react react react finite
players play to beat the people around
them infinite players play better than
themselves to wake up every single day
and say how can we make our company a
better version of itself today how can
we create a product this week that's
better than the product depleted last we
also have to play games not about being
ranked number one it's not about having
more followers on Twitter than your
friends it's not about outdoing anyone
it's about how to outdo yourself it's
not about selling more books or getting
more Ted views than somebody else it's
about how to make sure that the work
that you're producing is better than
your work we produced before
[Music]
you are your competition and that is
what ensures you stay in the game the
longest
[Music]
and that is what ensures you find joy
because the joy comes not from
comparison but from advancement
[Music]
when are you at your best
I'm at my best when I'm around people
who believe what I believe the boys are
going to rise up I know it seems silly
but I try very very hard to sort of
stack the deck and to put myself in a
position of strength
so for example you know somebody asked
me just yesterday have you ever had sort
of a bad engagement I'm like not really
but it's not because I'm some sort of
sort of genius a nice ending anything
like that
[Music]
it's because I stack the day well I
think it was shocking odds in the papers
the director I think it is I think you
have to discover what you're uniquely
great at because I want to be there I
want to be around people who want me
there in other words if I'm somebody's
tenth choice you know I'll probably turn
it down whereas if I'm their first
choice they really want me there and so
I'm I'm more likely to have a good
engagement they're supportive of me I'm
supportive of them when I choose to be
in an environment where where my
strengths are are there Nelson Mandela
is a particularly special case study in
the leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief and he was asked one day how did
you learn to be a great leader and he
responded that he would go with his
father and he remembers two things when
his father would meet with other elders
one they would always sit in a circle
and to his father was always the last to
speak you will be told your whole life
that you need to learn to listen I would
say that you need to learn to be the
last to speak I see it in boardrooms
every day of the week even people who
consider themselves good leaders who may
actually be decent leaders will walk
into a room and say here's the problem
here's what I think but I'm interested
in your opinion let's go around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself until everyone has
spoken
does two things
one it gives everybody else the feeling
that they have been heard it gives
everyone else the ability to feel that
they have contributed and two you get
the benefit of hearing what everybody
else has to think before you render your
opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes if you disagree
with somebody don't not know sit there
take it all in and the only thing you're
allowed to do is ask questions so that
you can understand what they mean and
why they have the opinion that they have
you must understand from where they are
speaking why they have the opinion they
have not just what they are saying and
at the end you will get your turn it
sounds easy it's not
[Music]
practice being the last to speak that's
what Nelson Mandela did
every decision we make in our lives as
individuals or as organizations is a
piece of communication it's our way of
saying something about who we are and
what we believe I think we you I've been
being myself since I was 19 this is why
authenticity matters this is why you
have to say and do the things you
actually believe because the things you
say and do are symbol of who you are
and we look for those symbols so we can
find people who believe what we believe
our very survival depends on
so if you're putting out false symbols
you will attract people to those symbols
but you won't be able to form trust with
them you're never gonna make it to the
big time
if you're just a copy of somebody else
this is what Tiger Woods did to it alive
alive
[Music]
he told us what he thought we wanted to
hear
and it was great and we were drawn to it
and all of us who kind of liked that
idea of that sort of the good guy
we're drawn to it until we found out it
was unlocked he could have been the bad
boy of golf he could have had all the
same endorsements and had a fantastic
career and still been hailed with one of
the great athletes of our day but he
didn't he chose to lie
good luck woman trust again tiger we
don't believe we don't trust
[Music]
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe when you do
what you believe you will attract people
to you the only one you're gonna kill me
win is if you're capable ooh that's it
that's really what you're gonna win
everybody else is taken if you go to one
of your friends and you say to one of
your friends how would you like me to
dress so that you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak so that you're
like me anymore right your friends are
gonna looking good what are you talking
about
come on come on come on shot what should
I wear so that you'll find me more
appealing and how would you like me to
speak to you so that you'll like me more
and why don't worry about my stuff and
talking my channel and your friends are
gonna tell you just be yourself that's
[Music]
why I like you I don't just be yourself
now think about what we do in industry
what do we do we do market research and
we go and we ask the customers what kind
of things the way with what style should
we speak to you how should we decorate
ourselves what kind of things are you
drawn to so that we can do those things
do you like us more it's just as
ridiculous organizations should say and
do the things they actually believe and
they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying cynicism sets in and
people start saying I'm not sure I can
trust these guys because there's not a
lot of consistency and all the things
they say and do which means they can't
have a very strong belief set or they're
lying to me
[Music]
and we're calling it open the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be is inauthentic
that's hilarious to me all these
positioning studies we do are inherent
we're gonna do a study to find out from
people so we can be more authentic
that's hilarious
saying dude you actually believe in the
symbols you put out there the things you
say and the things you do those red hats
are ways that people can find you what
you have the ability to do is create
those symbols and allow people to use
those things to say something about who
they are work for companies work for
clients work for people who you believe
what they believe show up and feel a
part of something bigger than yourself
and your part is to put what they
believe into pictures and words and
symbols and graphics so that other
people can use those things to say
something about who they are people put
harley-davidson logos on their body to
say something about who they are
corporate logo ain't no Procter &
Gamble's tattooed on anybody's on
because Harley means something they
stand for something
people put that tattoo on there not to
tell you that they own a motorcycle
they put that tattoo there to tell you
something about themselves if you get
your feet wet you feel kind of pit road
who you are trying to figure what value
can bring to it you ever see anybody
with a with a Mac laptop this sticker
over that beautiful shining Apple ain't
never gonna happen but somewhere along
the line you have to keep the right okay
well I I want to add give us to anybody
with a PC break out the Windex to clean
out their computer Mac people have you
ever seen the dirty Mac doesn't exist
does not exist why because it's Who I am
don't try to be the neck anybody who
need to vent view these are symbols we
use the companies that are crystal clear
and what they believe and their
discipline and how they do it they're
consistent what they do and everything
they say and everything they do serves
is a symbol of the set of values at
least we use those symbols to say
something about to leave their art into
what they are making and if you don't do
that you're always going to play second
third you're always going to be way down
on the list we surround ourselves but
the people and the products and the
brands that say something about who we
are and when we can find the people who
believe what we believe
we're weirdly drawn
because our very survival depends on we
need it it takes a lot of guts it takes
a lot of courage to be up in degree you
so the more you can give of yourself the
more you can give of what you believe
the more you can play most discipline
same and do the things you actually
believe strange things start to happen
you starting up into you what are your
thoughts and what's your approach
finding building upon
passion is not an actionable word it's
correct you know that those who do the
things that they're passionate about do
better but it's not helpful advice and
so the question is where does passion
passion is a result passion ISM energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that you
love
passion is the healing you have that you
would probably do this for free you know
and you can't believe somebody pays you
to do it
[Music]
and I think we mistake that passion is
something we do in our private lives but
it shouldn't be done in our careers for
example
and I'm a firm believer that you are who
you are and anybody who says I'm
different at home than I am at work and
one of those two places your life and
the goal is to make everything you do in
home edit work something that you have
excitement to do so how do you find the
thing that you're excited to do well
it's actually easier than you think
[Music]
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free
how can you recreate that feeling and
and be papered so what are the things
that I do on the weekend I love to go to
museums and galleries but I love to go
see dance and performances because I
want to see how others are interpreting
the world so that inspires me new ideas
new book new ways of looking at the
world
I seek it out and pay money for it does
that mean I have to have a career in the
arts
no it means I have to have a career
where new ideas are explored where
people are experimenting and trying
things out and I have to explore new
ideas and try things out and I'm just as
excited to go to work everyday as I am
to you know go do something on a
Saturday night and so the idea of
finding your passion is ironically
simple because you should be doing stuff
that you enjoy sometimes what is the
stuff that you enjoy and then what does
stuff you love
who the people that you love and what
are this where they all have how do you
explain when others are able to achieve
things that seem to defy all of the
assumptions why is Apple so innovative
they're more innovative than all their
competition and yet they're just a
computer company they're just like
everyone else they have the same access
to the same talent the same agencies the
same consultants the same media then why
is it that they seem to have something
different why is it that Martin Luther
King led the civil rights movement he
wasn't the only man who suffered in a
pre-civil Rights America and he
certainly wasn't the only great orator
of the day why him and why is it that
the Wright brothers were able to figure
out control powered man flight when
there were certainly other teams who
were better qualified but her funded and
they didn't achieve powered mid-flight
the Wright brothers beat them to it
there's something else at play here
about three and a half years ago I made
a discovery and this discovery
profoundly changed my view on how I
thought the world worked and it even
profoundly changed the way in which I
operate in it there's a pattern as it
turns out all the great and inspiring
leaders and organizations in the world
whether it's Apple or Martin Luther King
or the Wright brothers they all think
act and communicate the exact same way
and it's the complete opposite to
everyone else and it's probably the
world's simplest idea I call it the
Golden Circle
why how what this little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire where others aren't
let me define the terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows what
they do 100 percent some know how they
do it but very very few people or
organizations know why they do what they
do and by why I don't mean to make a
profit that's a result it's always a
result by why I mean what's your purpose
what's your cause what's your belief why
does your organization exist why do you
get out of bed in the morning and why
should anyone care well as a result the
way we think the way we act the way we
communicate is from the outside in it's
obvious we go from the clearest thing to
the fuzziest thing but the inspired
leaders and the inspire or inspired
organizations all think act and
communicate from the inside out let me
give you an example if Apple were like
everyone else a marketing message from
them might sound like this we make great
computers they're beautifully designed
simple to use and user friendly want to
buy one and that's how most of us
communicate that's how most marketing is
done that's how most sales done and
that's how most of us communicate
interpersonally we say what we do we say
how we're different or how we better and
we expect some sort of behavior or
purchase of something like that here's
our new law firm we have the best
lawyers with the biggest clients we have
you know we always perform for our
clients do business with us here's our
new car it gets great gas mileage it has
you know leather seats by our car but
it's uninspiring
here's how Apple actually communicates
people who are crazy enough to think
they can change the world are the ones
who do everything we do we believe in
challenging the status quo we believe in
thinking differently the way we
challenge the status quo is by making
our products beautifully designed simple
to use and user friendly we just happen
to make great computers wanna buy one
totally different right you ready to buy
a computer from me all I did was reverse
the order of the information what it
proves to us is that people don't buy
what you do people buy why you do it
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it
this explains why every single person in
this room is perfectly comfortable
buying a computer from Apple but we're
also perfectly comfortable buying an mp3
player from Apple or a phone from Apple
or a DVR from Apple but as I said before
Apple is just a computer company there's
nothing that distinguishes them
structurally from any of their
competitors their competitors are all
equally qualified to make all of these
products in fact they tried a few years
ago gateway came out with flat-screen
TVs they're eminently qualified to make
flat-screen tvs they've been making
flat-screen monitors for years nobody
bought one Dell came out with mp3
players and PDAs and they make great
quality products and they can make
perfectly well design products and
nobody bought one in fact talking about
it now we can't even imagine buying an
mp3 player from Dell why would you buy
an mp3 player from a computer company
but we do it every day people don't buy
what you do they buy why you do it the
goal is not to do business with
everybody who needs what you have the
goal is to do business with people who
believe what you believe
here's the best part
none of what I'm telling you is my
opinion it's all grounded in the tenets
of biology not psychology biology if you
look at a cross-section of the human
brain looking from the top
what you see is the human brain is
actually broken into three major
components that correlate perfectly with
the golden circle our newest brain our
Homo Sapien brain our neocortex
corresponds with the what level the
neocortex is responsible for all of our
rational and analytical thought and
language the middle tooth sections make
up our limbic brains and our limbic
brains are responsible for all of our
feelings like trust and loyalty it's
also responsible for all human behavior
all decision-making and it has no
capacity for language in other words
when we communicate from the outside in
yes people can understand vast amounts
of complicated information like features
and benefits and facts and figures just
doesn't drive behavior when we
communicate from the inside out we're
talking directly to the part of the
brain that controls behavior and then we
allow people to rationalize it with the
tangible things we say and do this is
where gut decisions come from you know
sometimes you can give somebody all the
facts and your figures in these I know
what all the facts in detail save it it
just doesn't feel right why would we use
that verb it doesn't feel right because
the part of the brain that controls
decision-making doesn't control language
and the best we can muster up is I don't
know it just doesn't feel right where
sometimes you say you're leading with
your heart or you're leading with your
soul well I hate to break it to you
there's owned the other body parts
controlling your behavior it's all
happening here in your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making and not language but if
you don't know why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do how will you ever get people to
to vote for you or buy something from
you or more importantly be loyal and
want to be a part of what it is what you
bet you do again the goal is not just as
to sell people who need what you have
the goal is to sell to people who
believe what you believe
the goal is not just to hire people who
need a job it's to hire people who
believe what you believe I always say
that hire people just because they can
do a job they'll work for your money but
if you hire people who believe what you
believe they work for you with blood and
sweat and tears but nowhere else is
there a better example of this than with
the right
most people don't know about Samuel
Pierpont Langley and back in the early
20th century the pursuit of powered man
flight was like the dot-com of the day
everybody was trying it and Samuel
Pierpont Langley had what we assume to
be the recipe for success Samuel
Pierpont Langley was given $50,000 by
the War Department to figure out this
flying machine money was no problem he
held a seat at Harvard and worked at the
Smithsonian and was extremely
well-connected he knew all the big minds
of the day he hired the best minds money
could find and the market conditions
were fantastic
the New York Times followed him around
everywhere and everyone was rooting for
Langley and how come we've never heard
of Samuel Pierpont Langley a few hundred
miles away in Dayton Ohio Orville and
Wilbur Wright they had none of what we
consider to be the recipe for success
they had no money they paid for their
dream with the proceeds from their
bicycle shop not a single person on the
Wright brothers team had a college
education
not even Orville or Wilbur and the New
York Times followed them around nowhere
the difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a caused by a purpose by
a belief they believed that if they
could figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he wanted to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches and lo
and behold look what happened the people
who believed in the Wright brothers
dream worked with them with blood and
sweat and tears the others just worked
for the paycheck
and they tell stories of how every time
the Wright brothers went out they would
have to take five sets of parts because
that's how many times they would crash
before they came in for supper and
eventually on December 17th 1903 the
Wright brothers took flight and no one
was there to even experience it we found
out about it a few days later further
proof that Langley was motivated by the
wrong thing but day the Wright brothers
took flight he quit he could have said
that's an amazing discovery guys and I
will improve upon your technology but he
didn't he wasn't first he didn't get
rich he didn't get famous so he quit
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and if you talk about what
you believe you will attract those who
believe what you believe well why is it
important to attract those who believe
what you believe something called the
law of diffusion of innovation and if
you don't know the law you definitely
know the terminology the first two and a
half percent of our population are our
innovators the next thirteen and a half
percent of our population are our early
adopters the next 34% are your early
majority your late majority and your
laggards the only reason these people by
touch-tone phones is because you can't
buy rotary phones anymore we all sit at
various places at various times on the
scale but with the law of diffusion of
innovation tells us is that if you want
mass-market success or mass-market
acceptance of an idea you cannot have it
until you achieve this tipping point
between 15 and 18 percent market
penetration and then the system tips and
I love asking businesses what's your
conversion on new business and they love
to tell you oh it's about 10% proudly
well you can trip over 10% of the
customers we all have about 10% who just
get it that's how we describe them right
that's like that gut feeling oh they
just get it the problem is how do you
find the ones that just get it before
you're doing business with them versus
the ones who don't get it
so it's this here this little gap that
you have to close as Jeffrey Moore calls
about crossing the chasm because you see
the early majority will not try
something until someone else has tried
it first
and these guys the innovators in the
early adopters they're comfortable
making those gut decisions they're more
comfortable making those intuitive
decisions that are driven by what they
believe about the world and not just
what product is available these are the
people who stood on line for six hours
to buy an iPhone when they first came
out when you could have just walked into
the store the next week and bought one
off the shelf these are the people who
spent $40,000 on flat-screen TVs when
they first came out even though the
technology was substandard and by the
way they didn't do it because the
technology was so great they did it for
themselves it's because they wanted to
be first people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it and what you do
simply proves what you believe in fact
people will do the things that prove
what they believe the reason that person
bought the iPhone on the first in the
first six hours of stood and strictly in
line for six hours was because of what
they believed about the world and how
they wanted everybody to see them they
were first people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it so let me give
you a famous example a famous failure
and a famous success of the law of
diffusion of innovation first the famous
failure look at TiVo from the time TiVo
came out about eight or nine years ago
to this current day they are the single
highest quality product on the market
hands down there is no dispute they were
extremely well-funded market conditions
were fantastic I mean we use TiVo as a
verb like TiVo stuff on my piece of junk
Time Warner DVR all the time but TiVo is
a commercial failure they've never made
money and when they went IPO their stock
was at about 30 or 40 dollars then
plummeted and it's never traded above 10
in fact I don't think it's even traded
above 6 except for a couple of little
spikes because you see when TiVo
launched their product they told us all
what they had they said we have a
product that pauses live TV skips
commercials rewinds live TV and
memorizes your viewing habits without
you even asking and the cynical majority
said we don't believe you we don't need
it
don't like it you're scaring us what if
they had said if you're the kind of
person who likes to have total control
over every aspect of your life boy do we
have a product for you it pauses live TV
skips commercials memorizes your viewing
habits etc etc people don't buy what you
do they buy why you do it and what you
do simply serves as the proof of what
you believe now let me give you a
successful example of the law of
diffusion of innovation in the summer of
1963 250,000 people showed up on the
mall in Washington to hear dr. King
speak they sent out no invitations and
there was no website to check the date
how do you do that well dr. King wasn't
the only man in America who was the who
was a great orator he wasn't the only
man in America who suffered in a
pre-civil Rights America in fact some of
his ideas were bad but he had a gift he
didn't go around telling people what
needed to change in America you know he
went around and told people what he
believed I believe I believe I believe
he told people and people who believe
what he believed took his cause and they
made it their own and they told people
and some of those people created
structures to get the word out to even
more people and lo and behold 250,000
people showed up on the right day on the
right time to hear him speak how many of
them showed up for him zero they showed
up for themselves it's what they
believed about America that got them to
travel on a bus for eight hours to stand
in the Sun in Washington for in the
middle of August it's what they believed
and it wasn't about black versus white
25% of the audience was white dr. King
believed that there are two types of
laws in this world those that are made
by a higher authority and those that are
made by man and not until all the laws
that are made by man are consistent with
the laws that are made by the higher
authority well we live in a just world
it just so happens that the civil rights
movement
was the perfect thing to help him bring
his cause to life we followed not him
not for him but for ourselves and by the
way he gave the I have a dream speech
not the I have a planned speech listen
to politicians now with the
comprehensive 12-point plans are not
inspiring anybody because there were
leaders and there are those who lead
leaders hold a position of power or
authority but those who lead inspire us
with other individuals or organizations
we follow those who lead because we have
to but because we want to we follow
those who lead not for them but for
ourselves and it's those who start with
Y that have the ability to inspire those
around them or find others who inspire
them
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Lex Ben de
Herrick asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you would like
me to profile next please leave it down
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you today what
did Simon say that had the biggest
impact what change you're gonna make to
your life your business after watching
this video please leave it down the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
decision making is a process right the
question is what filters are you using
to make decisions are you making
decisions based on the financial rewards
are you making decisions based on how
easy the work will be I mean I remember
in college you know they would give you
this book where they all the students
would rate the classes and they would
rate things like how easy the class was
and how you know how much do you they
like the professor and you know the
first year I picked all my classes based
on it workload and I picked everything a
low workload you know and pretty bored
didn't work very hard which was fine but
nothing was dynamic and nothing really
excited me and I thank goodness learned
that and so this second year I picked
all my classes by professor rating
regardless of the workload so every
class I had I had these dynamic amazing
incredible human beings passing on their
knowledge and you were excited to work
hard for them you know and so again what
the question is what are the filters
we're using and so if you're only
chasing the mighty dollar then you will
have jobs that'll pay you a little more
than the last but are you enjoying
yourself and I talked to a guy recently
who was enough he's in bad shape
like he really hates his life and he's
really depressed he doesn't know what to
do and so we were going through all his
old jobs you know and I said give me a
job that you've loved and he hadn't
every single job he's chosen out of
college he picked because of the the
money and if something offered him more
somewhere else he took it you know
regardless and and and and the amazing
thing is he plateaued because if you're
only chasing the result if you're only
chasing the thing that makes it easy
right
then eventually you will get bored or
they'll get bored of you right and you
plateau in other words chasing the old
mighty dollar if that's your only thing
it eventually flattens out whereas if
you're chasing the thing that excites
you the human beings to be around the
work that excites you the stuff that you
know you know you you can get passionate
about you know the the irony is is
you'll actually make way way more right
because you're excited and they
appreciate your excitement and they
reward your excitement and you're better
at your work because you want to work
harder and all of that stuff you don't
have to strain to work harder so
decision-making is simply a matter of
filters you know and so I've made
decisions in my life that I would rather
be happy than right I'd rather do good
then then get rich and and so the
decisions I make put me in positions
where when I leave any engagement when I
leave any meeting I feel that I've
contributed right rare are the times
anymore where you walk arguing just
think of the money just think of the
money think of the money you know I I
because that doesn't feel nice and and
the experience I have I don't enjoy
traveling to them and I don't enjoy
traveling home we're having amazing
experience I am looking forward to
getting there and I'm excited when I
leave you know so it's just decision
make decision-making is just a matter of
what filters you use and if you're if
you're good about keeping those filters
up and clear then then make your
decision I don't judge anybody by how if
they choose to use different filters
these are just the filters I choose to
live my life you know not right or wrong
just those are my decisions
you know that's my filter how can you
help the human race how can you help the
human race the human species progress
I'm not joking either this is something
I think we all have to be aware of at
the end of the day the human animals are
social animal and our very survival
depends on our ability to form
communities to form cultures what's a
community what's a culture it's a group
of people with a common set of values
and beliefs right what's a country it's
a group of people with a common set of
values and beliefs
what's a company it should be a group of
people with a common set of values and
beliefs when we're surrounded by people
who believe what we believe something
remarkable happens Trust emerges
and make no mistake of it trust as a
feeling a distinctly human feeling you
know we all have friends we're total
screw-ups and yet we still trust them
right Trust is not a checklist simply
doing everything you say you're going to
do doesn't that much does not mean
people will inherently trust you it just
means you're reliable
we need trust right we need trust when
we're surrounded by people who believe
what we believe and Trust starts to
emerge when we trust them and they trust
us we're more willing to take risks
we're more willing to experiment which
requires failure we're more willing to
explore and go somewhere with that no
one has ever gone before with the
confidence that if we fail if we trip
over if we turn our backs that those
within our community those who we trust
and who trust us will look after us
while we're gone will pick us up when we
fall over will help us when we're hurt
our very survival depends on it we're
not good at everything we're not good by
ourselves you know if I send you out to
go find a saber-toothed tiger by
yourself odds are Tiger one you zero
it's not gonna go very well but if you
go out as a group we're pretty damn
amazing and the reason is is because we
all have our strengths and we all of our
certain weaknesses and the goal is not
to fix your weaknesses the goal is to
amplify your strengths and surround
yourself with the people who can do what
you can't do but it's not just based on
skills and an application and experience
it's based on what you believe it's
based on what you believe you see simply
being good at something and having
somebody else being good what you're no
good at does not mean you will trust
each other trust the sense of trust
comes from the sense of common values
and common beliefs I can prove it how
many of you from New York okay a bunch
of you are you friends with everybody in
New York why not why not but when you go
to Los Angeles and you meet someone from
New York you're like hey I'm from New
York and you're best friends right and
when you go to France you there you are
in the Paris Metro minding your own
business and you hear an American accent
behind you and you turn around you say
hey where're you from
they say Los Angeles you're like hey I'm
from New York
your best friends because when you're
surrounded by people who don't believe
what you believe when you're in a
strange environment where you don't feel
comfortable you look for anyone who may
share some of the same values and
beliefs that you have and you start to
form a very wheat real and very intense
bond with them simply because you know
that they have a basic understanding of
how you grew up of the things that you
care about of the life that you live
back home well the same is true when we
go to work do we want to go to work with
people who understand us who believe
what we believe who have a similar view
of the world that has nothing to do with
their opinions and the differences that
we share
that's good that's called diversity
that's called advantages to problem
solving which is we can all look at the
same thing from a different angle and
come up with solutions what I'm talking
about is why should you help each other
in the first place what are you in
pursuit of now the question is is what
creates that sense of values and beliefs
what creates that sense of trust right
our very human instinct we know how to
find people who believe what we believe
our survival depends on it we're
biologically gifted with this idea if I
ask you to go out in the street and find
all the people who believe what you
believe you know exactly what to do
you're gonna strike up conversations
you're gonna start talking to people and
usually either you'll have a good
feeling about them or you won't either
you'll have chemistry whatever that
means or you don't
sometimes it's quick sometimes it's slow
but we know how to do it it's called
making friends it's called dating it's
called networking we have the innate
ability to do it true story there was a
former Undersecretary of Defense who was
invited to give a speech at a large
conference about a thousand people and
he was standing on the stage with his
cup of coffee in a Styrofoam cup giving
his prepare to March with his PowerPoint
behind him and he took a sip of his
coffee and he smiled and he looked down
at the coffee and then he went
off-script
and he said you know last year I spoke
at this exact same conference last year
I was still the undersecretary and when
I spoke here last year they flew me here
business class and when I arrived at the
airport there was somebody waiting for
me to take me to my hotel and they took
me to my hotel mayor ready
check me in and they just took me up to
my room and the next morning I came
downstairs and there was someone waiting
in the lobby to greet me and they drove
me to this here same venue they took me
through the back entrance and took me
into the green room and handed me a copy
cup of coffee in a beautiful ceramic cup
he says I'm no longer the undersecretary
I flew here coach I took a taxi to my
hotel and I checked myself in when I
came down the lobby this morning I took
another taxi to this venue I came in the
front door and found my way backstage
and when I asked someone do you have any
coffee he pointed to the coffee machine
in the corner and I poured myself a cup
of coffee into this here Styrofoam cup
he says the lesson is the ceramic cup
was never meant for me it was meant for
the position I held I deserved a
Styrofoam cup remember this as you gain
Fame as you gain fortune as you gain
position and seniority people will treat
you better they will hold doors open for
you they will get you a cup of tea and
coffee without you even asking they will
call you sir and ma'am and they will
give you stuff none of that stuff is
meant for you that stuff is meant for
the position you hold it is meant for
the level that you have achieved of
leader or success or whatever you want
to call it but you will always deserve a
Styrofoam cup remember that remember
that lesson of humility and gratitude
you can accept all the free stuff you
can accept all the perks absolutely you
can enjoy them but just be grateful for
them and know that they're not for you I
remember getting off the Acela I took
the Acela from New York to Washington DC
and I got off the train like everybody
else and I was walking down the platform
like everyone else
and I walked past general norty Schwartz
who used to be the chief of staff of the
United States Air Force the head of the
Air Force and here I did
see a guy in a suit slepping his own
suitcase down the platform just like me
and just a couple months ago he was
flying on private jets and an entourage
and other people carried his luggage but
he no longer held the position and so
now he got to drag his own suitcase and
never did it sort of remind me more that
none of us deserve the perks that we get
we all deserve a Styrofoam cup